voici également des salariés
une magnifique robe bonjour thierry ses
alliés un petit souci donc à lens il ya
du monde mais on peut douter mais son
succès mondial s'est dit voilà je viens
chez ardisson et même parler de cul pas
du tout on va parler de tes nichons
comment ça va tu es magnifique 7 qui
cette fraude c'est vivienne westwood à
la bogue sur chouette elle fait des
trucs c'est la première fois que je
porte une robe qu'elle va prêter soit
farrell les personnes qui travaillent
pour elle et tout et je la remercie
beaucoup c'est vrai pas lui aussi yann
westwood alors clémentine est ce que
votre père regarde mes jambes oui oui
oui forcément on a mis bon il m'a dit
quand thierry ardisson te demandent des
choses sexuelles ma chérie dis lui que
ces choses intimes que tu n'as pas
forcément partager avec tout le monde je
suis là mais pas il aime pas quand vous
parlez de ça on n'y a pas que lui qui
une fois des amis n'ont pas tremblé j'ai
la trouille ces vilains ce soir c'est
pourquoi c'est pas parce que vous avez
votre émission à la elle s'est épanouie
que la a coûté cela elle ne doit pas y
aller un peu copié dans l'émission
quelle est bonne alors justement on va
rester sur votre père parce qu'il
travaille à la télé oui il était
rédacteur en chef pour tf1 et c'est un
type très intègre votre père il était
très choqué par les moeurs de la télé et
vous dites souvent ils rentrent et
malheureux le soir à la maison j'ai
souvenir l'un avec quelques fois pas
tout à toulon mais des fois ce titre est
un peu déchiré par oui et puis ce
n'était pas quelqu'un qui reconstituait
l'actualité pour que ce soit plus
sensationnel dramatique avec le nahd
quoi ou alors vous dites vous suite à
toute cette expérience j'ai vécu avec
votre permis
la télévision est un métier monstrueux
où est malhonnête n'est pas grave
oui enfin super d'être difficile est de
rester vraiment un gars vraiment ce
qu'on veut c'est le centre yann ses
spectacles mais c'est vrai que de dire
la vérité combien d' avance bien
alors vous vous étiez beaucoup de
concessions notre carrière pour y
arriver
ben non pas beaucoup au début pourtant
vous allez accepter très facilement de
changer de nom donc on est arrivé à un
radio 7
meriem en frais bah ouais mme patrick
meyer vous a demandé vous appelez
clémentine j'ai dit oui tout de suite
avait pas de problème
oui puisque c'était pour rigoler ils
disent là la gym a été assez je m'en
foutais voit l'actrice voilà est
heureuse on ne sait pas garder non que
beineix j'avais besoin de reprendre
cette 2e vous souvenez sûrement de
beineix non je suis dit ça c'est que le
diable porcine est non alors que vous
étiez au départ prête à faire certaines
concessions tout avait changé votre nom
assez rapidement et puis après non et
puis après c'était fini par exemple
quand il monte on vous a sauté dessus au
standard de radio france pour moi le
sexe est liée à l'amour on voit les
quelqu'un qui vous drague comme ça mais
en plus je respecte un homme absolument
génial mais après vous vous êtes viré
une espèce d'image vous avez quelqu'un
de et puis après vous voyez que c'est un
homme enfin je veux dire il a bon il
nous a dit qu'il pouvait vous aider oui
bah oui puisqu'il voulait développer des
produits les bons gars et ça je peux te
des petites
en fait il y avait une [ __ ] dans la tête
c'est fait
tous les meubles un jour j'ai dit à
trouver juste rétablie que je faisais un
truc très vulgaire très grossier c'est
pas chez moi je fais pas le genre de
l'émission j'ai dit bon je vais faire
engueuler jeudi qu'il fallait
si c'est débile pour arriver dans le
cinéma ouais ce que je voulais dire par
là c'est que moi je n'ai pas fait ça
parce qu'il est il est tout à fait
déplacé que ce soit pour enfin avec ça
qu'on doive enfin qu'on a
que ce soit grâce à ça qu'on arrive à
voir si ça c'est pas que grâce à sa part
mehdi c'est les gens qui s'étaient parlé
pour vous en faites alors vous parliez
pour les autres voilà voilà
ces récents des millions de gens non en
fait sérieusement votre refus des
concessions clémentine vous a mis dans
une position assez marginal dans le
métier oui c'est pas génial
un nom wii fait ça a commencé à l'école
à l'école vous dit quand vous en parlez
de votre cette période vous dites déjà
j'étais trop grande trop encombrante
avec un et deux boxeuses alors que je
rêvais d'être diaphane et névrosée oui
j'avais envie d'être j'ai passé fin fine
voyez sur m6 va très jolie arrêté merci
mais maintenant j'ai d'abord chez une
femme voyez ça que j'étais une femme
avant avant d'essaimer jeunes filles
voilées
c'est pour ça que enfin gérard été
formés très jeune un compte et parce que
meiway on a parlé de l c'était neuf en
temps et alors vous dites c'est la même
chose aujourd'hui parce que dans ce
métier aujourd'hui je me sens souvent un
peu au fond de la classe près du
radiateur
oui en ce moment au cinéma
oui je comprends pas je vous jure non
mais bon c'est pas grave parce que je
suis vraiment heureuse en france qui ces
deux événements dans ma grand voile à
est ce assez
mais c'est le pied et mai mais il ya des
moments où il ya un an je fais des
crises de cafard terry vraiment mais
parce que je ne comprenais pas mais bon
c'est pas grave ce que je veux dire le
plus pur soit parce que des fois vous
êtes un peu démesuré c'est non vous
savez pas mais oui mais enfin votre
façon de faire les choses à fond
clémentine s'il avait su plus tôt que
j'étais comme 5 sera comme ça j'aurais
peut-être plus vite fait mon chemin tout
seul
peut-être peut-être y était plus
mystérieuse un peu comme catherine
deneuve très comme ça c'est la fille qui
dirigea la com non j'étais prêt marginal
en fait j'ai lu dans un journal que vous
passiez votre temps les boîtes gay
j'aime beaucoup acheté pas nous marier
là c'est quoi cette histoire et je ne
sais pas pourquoi j'aime les boîtes peu
parce que le sang je me sens en fait
libres parce que j'ai l'impression qu'il
n'ya pas tous ces trucs alors la drague
et puis de machins et puis non mais oui
quoique bien non alors donc pourquoi
clémentine célarié mais pas mariés
pourquoi n'est-elle pas marié d'abord -
le passé beaucoup de temps dans les
boîtes gay on vient de le dire
et puis c'est vrai nom c'est vrai que
vous faites une idée très très
midinettes du mariage c'est monstrueux
un autre comment ça se fait ça je sais
pas il faudra demander je ne sais pas
j'ai ouïe pour moi c'est le truc absolue
passionnel tous ceux qui me disent oui
mais bon je suis très entière forcément
tant que 10
mais tu sais impossible à présent d hab
souvent fait ça ne m'intéresse pas ce
genre de discours je suis pas j'ai pas
l'impression d'avoir j'en suis pas là je
ne sais pas mais je crois qu'il ya un
compte et quand même vous marier un jour
je veux me marier
ah oui je me marie va lancer un appel
nous quoi chercher quoi non mais des
coupes chercher quoi comme type d'homme
on savait qu'ils soient mariés larusso
on a marié la récente ont dit non mais
la route on est venu ici un jour
désespérer là depuis de jules tout ça et
on a lancé un appel à trouver fabrice
quoi fabrice mais qui de la classe alors
bien sûr il ne supportait pas aussi
c'est l'enterrement de vie de jeune
fille non mais cette idée cette idée
qu'on arrête de rigoler lisez ce sont
ses intérêts
l'idée d'enterrer quelque chose pour
l'arrière est ce que vous imaginez ça
abominable alors moi si je me marie je
fais le jeu de foot commencer mais je
veux dire ce jeu non mais non mais je
vous en tire est vierge pure pour
l'homme j'ai mes nouveaux alors il ya un
problème j'ai trouvé en fait pourquoi
vous mariez pas c'est parce que vous
refusez d'assister au mariage vous fait
chier les mariages oui c'est dans ce
mariage les statistiques le prouvent
c'est dans les mariages qu'on rencontre
les gens avec qui on va se marier il
faut autre cause de votre marginalité
l'éclectisme de vos activités vous dites
je n'ai pas de carrière ce que je fais
c'est ma vie je vois pas pourquoi il
faut réduire visite le théâtre pour moi
c'est sacré oui c'est sacré parce que
c'est un endroit c'est une bulle et
c'est un endroit il ya des moments j'ai
envie que que d'être là en dehors des
enfants je préfère la plaintive un
werder des enfants en fait il ya que là
que je suis bien comme aux réfugiés aux
crocs ben oui dans le sud bisons ont
fait lui-même quand comment on fait
donc voila vous interprétez madame sans
gêne c'est une pièce de victorien sardou
là c'est la version de pierre laville
mise en scène donc à alain saxe alors là
vraiment existé cette année de songer à
na c'est le mélange de deux fins voilà
il ya la femme du maréchal lefebvre ex
blanchisseuse qui a été d'une fidélité
sans faille à son mari et à napoléon et
puis une fille de pontoise aussi ça fait
vraiment madame sans gêne donc on a
mélangé on a mélangé les deux alors le
rôle a quand même déjà été jouée par
réjane mistinguett jeunes source à
sophie desmarais arletty mêmes sophia
loren il a interprété le rôle au cinéma
alors au départ vous trouvé l'idée un
peu trop évidente oui je voulais rien je
voulais pas et puis c'est quelqu'un qui
a compté dans ma vie qui m'a dit
qui m'a dit tu t'étais fold et tout d'un
coup j'ai beau me suis dit oui et donc
j'ai appelé mon agent laurent grégoire
qui est un ami et puis voilà et puis on
attirant là qu'on l'a fait on a dit on
le fait et puis en fait un an s'est
passé et moi pendant ce temps là j'ai
écrit mon one man show je voulais faire
un one man show un spectacle tout seul
et puis et puis il était à la lecture au
théâtre antoine mais vraiment argument
je voulais plus fermés du tout et puis
et puis il s'est passé un truc dans ce
théâtre
incroyable mais tout d'un coup j'avais
raison de lire enfin mais moins bon et
puis tout le monde il y avait moyen de
100 jeunes mais évidemment que c'est oui
c'est vrai le 18 octobre donc au théâtre
antoine
ce n'est pas une comédie musicale alors
oui comme je chante aussi aider jean
prouvé en jeu tous
vous placez évidemment madame sans gêne
à ça ça c'est charles schillings et
pompons f donc c'est quand même le leur
en faudrait comment dans une boîte gay
aussi lui à la démence news à bruxelles
oui et c'était génial ça c'est mais pour
moi c'est extra qui sait de trucs là je
me dis qu'on aime sans gêne elle devrait
maintenant je pense que l'aura peut-être
aussi rencontre sarko on s'est
rencontrés dans cette boîte j'entends
des leçons qu'ils aient jamais bien
faire des impros à vaison j'ai des
copains qui ont déboîté tout ça et puis
et puis là je me suis dit je lui dis tu
as confiance en moi tu as un micro tout
ça je vais bien faire des impros un peu
avec des dj et là bas depuis c'est comme
si on était mariée alors lui c'est comme
un genre de mais non on n'est pas
ensemble il est très beau magnifique ne
veut pas de moi non mais je les
comprends je dis des conneries quand ça
non mais mais non mais c'est un mec
génial qui disait il à c'est un africain
métis ilaina un truc de roi